okay the cast the cast of The Fast and
Furious movies get more and more
incredible so let's go through some new
people in this latest one okay cuz we're
gonna start with Dame Helen mirin oh who
who would have thought like who would
have thought Dame Helen Mir like I just
it's incredible I was I love her she's
incredible yeah I love her she she came
here and I fell in love with her all
over again so what was it like like talk
about your first day meeting her ah
first day meeting her I was at a at my
agents's um
Oscar party and um she had been doing
interviews
saying they said what do you want to do
next and she's saying I want to be in
Fast and Furious and they're like what
and so she came up to me and she said um
hey Vin have you heard I want to be fast
and furious oh my God it's pretty good
and I'm like but really we're um we're
about to film in a week she said I don't
care you're the producer get it together
oh my
God she's so bold she was me to be a
part of the
movie please
don't I love it it was great and she's
amazing and what she brings she's so
talented yeah okay I'm going to go to
Brie Larson now is it true that her
character is based on your
daughter yes which is so great how proud
is your daughter that's so cool too God
yes so how so well she my older daughter
she came to my older daughter's birthday
and my younger daughter Pauline who I
named after Paul yeah um was wearing a
good vibes only
shirt and she just has this kind of
confidence and so she modeled the
character after after Pauline and it's
just the most adorable thing I love
that
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home